Let's say I have this green court
and there is air in it.
We assume that the molecules of air have
temperature and average
kinetic energy, but everyone will
there is a different speed, everyone will hit each other
and will move in different directions.
You may notice something on this drawing.
On the left side, I will draw
imaginary line, we can say that line
there is no real, structural significance,
does not split the court really, just use it to
denotes the left and right sides.
You see the left
higher concentration of molecules,
higher concentration.
How do we measure the concentration -
such as the number of molecules
in a given volume.
But here we see a cross-section of the court.
If we look at a portion of this size,
here we have four molecules,
it seems that we have four molecules, between three and five molecules
in part with this size,
but if I take part of that amount on the other side,
we have about one or two molecules.
These numbers are not very accurate, but
it is clear that we have a higher concentration here.
We have more molecules per unit area.
But to think in three dimensions, if we think of a volume,
we have a higher concentration on the left
and a lower concentration on the right,
lower concentration on the right.
When we have
higher concentration in one part of the container and lower in another,
we say we have a concentration gradient.
Concentration changes from higher to lower,
we call this concentration
concentration
concentration gradient.
What do you think will happen?
Let's say this is the situation,
which we see,
what do you think will happen?
All of these particles will hit each other
and things will shift to the left
to the right, will be displaced
from left to right. But we have
more particles to the left, which
can move to the right and fewer particles to the right,
which can be moved to the left.
Remember, they all move in different directions
at random speeds, but we have more particles on this side,
they will bounce around, so
at any time when we have
higher concentration on the left,
we have a greater chance of moving particles
from left to right,
than from right to left.
As time progresses,
the distribution of molecules in the container will look like this.
If we let this system stabilize,
if we let it stabilize
for a while, it will start to look like this.
Let's see if I can
to paint it well. I will draw
only the molecules, I will not paint
their velocity vectors.
If we wait a bit - How many molecules did we have?
One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
Now I have one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
If we wait long enough,
that we will no longer have
concentration gradient, concentration in all parts
the court will be aligned with time.
If I now draw this imaginary
dashed line,
I will have the same concentration on both sides,
there will no longer be a gradient,
there is no gradient.
This is not magic,
molecules have not said, "Oh, we have less concentration
on this side, you have somehow
to move from the other. ", you just have to know,
that molecules jump randomly around the court
and if we have a higher concentration on the left,
there is a better chance
the molecules on the left side go to the right,
than the molecules on the right side go to the left.
Even in this situation, molecules will move
from left to right and from right to left,
but now we have the same number on both sides.
Therefore, at any moment
there is the same likelihood that molecules will move
from left to right, as well as from
right to the left, so we come to a situation
of equilibrium.
Of course, if we take it
a unit of time, perhaps this molecule is moving
from left to right, this moves
from left to right,
this moves from left to right,
but because we have the same concentrations on both sides
there is the same likelihood that the same number of molecules will move
from right to left.
In this example, we have only 20,
only 20 particles,
which is quite artificial and small.
If we talk about concentrations
of air molecules,
or if we deal with cell membranes,
if we think of different types of molecules,
which are in aqueous solution,
we will have far more than 20 molecules.
If we think
for the probabilities of these huge numbers,
the probability that something moves from left to right
is the same as moving from right to left.
We will have this stability.
There is a much greater likelihood here
in every moment
something to move from right to left,
therefore we are observing the movement of
particles from a higher to a lower concentration.
Another way we can look at the matter is that
what we are watching is
diffusion in the direction of
the concentration gradient.
So the process we described is diffusion,
it's diffusion.
When we study different types of systems,
we will see that it is very important
for biological and even chemical systems,
because it does not require extra energy
for the movement of particles from here to there,
the movement will be probable,
of course. Again, this is not magic,
there are simply more molecules in this part
and a greater chance of moving from left to right,
rather than right-to-left.
I want this to be clear.
There may be a right-to-left movement,
for example, this molecule,
instead of moving in that direction,
it is quite possible to move
from right to left.
Not exactly every molecule moves from left to right,
but there is a better chance molecules can
move from left to right.
This molecule moves in that direction,
because there are more molecules here.
Everybody is bumping and jumping in different and
random directions.